let's get everything out of here tables
chairs table settings go in bins
everything out let's go where are we
going the staff meeting what's off the
chain we got a lot of anger out a lot of
points going on there and hopefully we
got to my boss
Chef Francie
he did his thing
what a mess
how many times a day do you clean no no
clean no cream no cleaning no cream when
was the last time somebody wiped this
[__] dust that's dripping into the food
that's above the hot plate when was last
time somebody talked to me
it's never been done
oh my God
are you [__] kidding me
and look at that in there
you cook food on top of that
it's so thick with Grime and [__] you
can't even see the grills anymore that's
not good at all when was last time that
was cleaned out Anthony I didn't I
didn't clean you haven't you've been
here 13 years well yeah I have cleaned
it years ago but come on guys
dare I my God it's like [__]
Halloween in here what's that there
Chuck a small black mold the most
dangerous [__] type oh my God
there's no dates on here this stuff it's
just a cesspit [__] it now
you are [__] kidding me raw beef with
cooked Fried Chicken oh my gosh more
chicken
more chicken
nine containers of fried [__] chicken
how much Fried Chicken does one
restaurant need have you calculated how
much money that we are wasting currently
a couple Grand easy minimum and you
wonder why you're the busy idiot running
around [__] five times a day looking
for a product and these guys can't even
get a [__] paycheck cashed here's
your [__] answer
what's kept in here yes I only see
fingers in there all the seafood
what's that that's oysters
gross it's all slimy an 87 year old lady
was sat having lunch with me today and
she said her oysters they don't smell
good were we serving with them minutes
ago I need your nose for one thing
though
they've been in about a week probably
truthfully
yes
[__]
Betty I understand why he's sweating
it's
a time bomb especially with oysters out
of the shell there's no oysters cut if
it's not Cottage Fried Chicken one two
three four five you should be ashamed
you're [__] lucky you haven't killed
anybody 81 years down the pan because we
can't stay clean you've been given a
lesson and you're playing with it
please tell me there's no other fridges
around
[__] you now
you are kidding me
come on guys
you have to be joking
I don't get it I don't get it
actually Decades of apples I brought in
here for everybody to eat that's where
it came from we don't even use them what
that's right we don't use those isn't
that what happened is that where those
apples came from are you saying that's
an excuse so I'm not saying as an excuse
I'm done with [__] seriously
I've asked Tara and Lou to step away so
the staff can speak more freely
somebody tell me truthfully what on
Earth is going on I don't know why he's
angry all the time we come in at four
o'clock and everybody's in a good mood
Yeah Yeah by 4 15 we're out here saying
you got to be kidding me he's miserable
back there and he wants to make some of
us miserable with him it's hard when you
come in and you have to see him like
belittle everybody around you because
that stresses me out it's hard to
concentrate get things done
you're a pastry chef right I do
everything actually yeah I do everything
out of all of you here how many have
considered quitting raise your hands
how many of you feels you've been abused
wow it's actually unreasonable and he
takes no accountability yeah
don't work like that
would work better when he's not there
why are you still here
I need the money you need the job I have
four kids
and currently a single mom I watch your
background
graduated culinary school in 98. with
two decades of experience does Lou
respect you as a chef
I think he he respects me as a cook but
not so much as a chef two different
things a cooking a chef how does that
make you feel I feel
not important
almost distant Palace
absolutely I need to work under people
that have
this man has a team underneath them that
have been handicapped yep I want to get
them both
Lou two seconds please would you come
back out please uh thank you
so Lou why are you so over controlling
and don't trust a single member of Staff
in here am I I'm not perfect what a
pathetic desperate answer
I wish I could come here and have so
much more input we can't work full-time
in a restaurant because we have kids you
know we have six kids between us we have
passion and we all like to do food Taya
loves food but I wish you would trust me
it's not about trust it's about what you
just said
some of the moms that do work in the
kitchen can't commit to what the kitchen
needs it's not that the moms are very
capable it's just working six nights
five nights a week it's being mumps
you have children
and my wife is able to be home with them
oh my God
this guy's a dinosaur
I've got something like 85 female chefs
and if they're good enough to be a head
chef three nights a week they get the
job if it's four nights a week they get
the job it's one night a week I believe
in Talent this man doesn't believe in
Talent
whether you're here three nights a week
two nights a week if you're good enough
doing that kitchen girl you run that
kitchen
Lou I was in there firsthand we've got a
camera in my hand I'm not impressed with
your behavior I'm disgusted with the way
you treat the staff and like I said I'm
done with your [__] excuses
and I would say I'm sorry guys
you're sat with your back to your team
you shrug your shoulders and you tell
them you're sorry oh boy you got a lot
of people that love you in this room
you don't have to be angry you can trust
us it's not just a job yeah we have a
lot on the line too because we got bills
to pay but we love you guys your family
your children
and let this genius in front of you help
you
I'm here to turn this place around
wither out him
smell it
people think this is exaggeration I'm
not [__] around
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to
apologize on their behalf
what you witnessed was appalling I am
gonna try my best to fix this place but
I would like
to ask you to come back in 24 hours from
now please
I appreciate it not 24 hours Starts Now
staff get on your cell phones because
nobody's going anywhere so you need to
roll up your sleeves and commit and get
this place out of the abyss and back on
the map
I just gotta let everyone know for like
the next 24 hours I won't be able to
answer anything so I'll be busy I'm
gonna call you back I just got a lot
going on today and I'll keep you updated
as soon as I know something
[Music]
I've just apologized to those patrons
Victoria what is your position here
it's a waitress
a waitress but the new manager as well
sometimes why because no one else is
here to do it wow why'd you stay here I
think it's a loyalty thing I've been
here since before we even opened so I
want to see this place succeed and I
want to be able to say I'm so proud of
the place I work at and how you feeling
right now
embarrassed
and used
I mean Jermaine is such a good person
he's not a bad guy at all at all
and
I want to help him as much as I can
and have so much time in my own money
into this place so your own money yeah
what does that mean I thought is this
past week because our ice maker doesn't
work it's came out of my pocket
Jermaine can I just have two minutes on
my own with the team please can you get
some fresh air just go for a walk please
foreign
oh boy you're now buying
items for the restrooms yeah that's
beyond loyal he's the owner you're not
the owner
Whitney why is Jermaine lost his way
he's just never I don't think he never
really had it leadership I can't say
that that's ever been anything that
Jermaine has ever why would a guy that
can't be assertive can't be a leader
can't motivate why would you open a
restaurant of all the businesses in the
world he just wanted to make his parents
feel proud of him make his parents feel
proud with this incarnation
oh man I didn't want him to open a
restaurant to be honest God told him I
know I think this is a bad idea
come here
[Music]
oh yeah yeah very depressing Jermaine do
you have any idea how to run a
restaurant not a clue not a clue this is
Major League this is money running out
the door costs that we've burned to keep
the lights on and the stove's hot is
insane like I said I didn't understand
what I was getting myself into until I
was already in it so I've been trying to
wake up never said don't do it
I said I'm here to help I am going to
start teaching you but you need to step
up otherwise there's no point me being
here is that clear yes sir I'm here to
make sure they can get back to business
as usual and that means some tough love
and starting over from scratch General
shall we yeah sure we're heading to
lunch at the Ellicott Mills Brewing
Company we have a table upstairs the
restaurant that is merging with The
Condemned Phoenix Emporium from down the
street if this is going to be a mainstay
I need to make sure the food will keep
the tourists coming back
good to see you good to see you as well
lovely Highway almost with this sort of
German influence Austrian wild ball
goulash it's a little bizarre menu right
now
what the [__] is that some weird ass
all right what can I guess schnitzel
okay I like to have the ribeye steak
please battered rock paper you did the
smoked pork chop okay thank you guys hey
Doc yo when you get a chance can you
throw it out some chicken
please and thank you certainly
an economy in general in terms of the
local businesses how hard is it for them
to survive in the current time it's been
difficult yeah absolutely sure stigma
yeah
[Music]
oh boy oh that thing look good
yeah you're still a red cabbage thank
you
I think it's a little color-wise yeah I
know a little draft
what did you get the uh schnitzel which
is pretty bland how was your evening got
a little gristle in here
a little tough there
the batter tastes pretty good the
Rockfish is a little dry
that's not mashed potatoes it's a German
potato salad
it's ice cold yeah oh my God ladies the
food wasn't a highlight but the company
was so nice to meet you buddy
now I just have your attention please
ladies and gentlemen I'm so sorry can
you get the whole kitchen Brigade to
come out into the dining room please
doc Nick can you come out front please
[Applause]
[Music]
Mark I just want to say whilst that
wasn't the best experience upstairs I
need you to know that I'm here to help
thank you what I need to do now is to
get everybody from the top of the
streets to the bottom of the street
outside the little market Cafe
urgently yes chef I'll see you outside
shortly
[Music]
[Applause]
see that is incredible
[Music]
he's here to help
[Applause]
come on
this is awesome
Gordon Ramsay's here no shame oh my gosh
let's go so we're gonna get yelled at
basically we're gonna get screened up
he's here to help let's go let's go
ladies and Gentlemen please
how are you
[Music]
here come here quick come here I'll
explain how are you I'm good oh my
goodness Me Oh My Goodness Me Is Right
are you okay I'm not okay can I borrow
you for two minutes please
so tall oh my God what is going on
please come out
what is happening
[Applause]
oh